et selon a dit abdul razeq président de
l'association des anciens auxiliaires de
l'armée française il est urgent que la
france accélère son processus
d'évacuation
le dernier attentat ne serait selon lui
que le début de la menace qui pèse sur
les familles afghanes bloqué à kaboul
je demande l'état français de facilité
de d'accélérer la
procédure d'évacuation pour les les
anciens auxiliaire de qui ont les
anciens auxiliaires de l'armée française
et pour une vingtaine d'autres familles
qui ont déjà le statut résidents de
france de faciliter et d'accélérer la
procédure d'évacuation pour qu'elle
puisse sauver leur vie et celle de leur
famille et on voit qu on ne reçoit
aucune réponse de la part des autorités
françaises bien sur sa selle de l'aude
ou de l'attak en fait le début de la
menace qui pèse actuellement sur nos
collègues qui restent qui se retrouvent
bloqués à l'aéroport de kaboul nous
espérons que l'état français accélère et
trouve une solution pour ceux qui auront
déjà collaboré l'armée française et de
sauver leur vie et celle de leur famille
mais après le 31 août la procédure se
sera encore compliqué et nos amis et ils
sont obligés de fuir de partir dans les
pieds limitrophes comme pakistan est
avantagé question